how to market your videos on youtube i
got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers alex who wrote in to say
that he's trying to get his youtube
channel started and he wrote in the same
curious how are you able to generate so
many thousands of viewers for your
videos is there a particular marketing
technique that you find to be very
effective sincerely alex and he goes on
to say you've seen lots of videos about
keywords name title etc uh he wanted my
unique approach to it so here's the
thing alex okay one simple rule if you
want your videos to do well
make your videos good
that's it you gotta have good stuff i
don't pay attention to the keywords i
don't pay attention to the description
to the summary to all the little tactics
and tricks
because at the end of the day what
people care about is watching good stuff
stop spending so much time on keyword
research and put it into making your
video better
look at my videos now compared to where
they used to be okay if you watch some
of my first videos
i'm much better
and it's come from making 900 videos
i spend my time practicing and getting
better it's why i record
10 to 15 videos every week
so i get better
the topics mostly coming from you guys
questions that come in from my audience
they wanna they want my answer on
something
so
make yourself better
practice
get to work
if you look at some of the most
successful videos of all time okay you
look at some of the ted talk videos it's
not like they're necessarily optimized
so well on their title that's not why
people are watching it they're watching
because the content is amazing
so that's what you need to focus on if
you have great keywords for example and
your video sucks
then people might find it but they're
not going to watch it
they're not going to stay past a couple
seconds they're not going to subscribe
to your channel they're not going to
comment and if you're thinking just in
in the ranking terms
you're not going to make it right if
you're not getting engagement if people
aren't watching your video it doesn't
matter how much keyword optimization you
have you're not gonna get your video
ranked
it reminds me of of the uh the older
days of seo right you you create a
website you create a page you just stuff
it with all the keywords all the
different tools and techniques and
tricks to get ranked and then people
will come to your site
but
if it's a piece of junk content they're
not going to take action they're not
going to buy anything from you and
google is starting to down rank those
and they want the content that people
actually pay attention to
so it's happening in youtube as well
less and less importance on what you tag
it and what description you use and if
you caption it or not and what the title
is
and more are people actually paying
attention to this are they watching it
are they liking it are they leaving
comments are they sharing it are they
embedding it and if you want that to
happen you have to create epic stuff
great stuff that is worth sharing
so if you had an hour a day to spend on
this i'd say spend that hour
forgetting about your research forget
about what keywords to use and just
create great stuff
belief
for those of you watching if you thought
this video is great if you like the
channel
please give this video a thumbs up below
let me know what you think you have a
question just like alex did you i'm
gonna answer for you leave it in the
comment section and if you liked the
video you want to see more subscribe to
the channel see you soon
believe and thank you for watching
you